hey guys and welcome to planet coaster
def tyree 3 i didn't originally plan to
make this video which is also why i'm
very late to the party but over the past
week many people have asked me about the
deaf diary and yesterday finally some
people convinced me to actually make
this response video to it so i suppose
if it take off your fancy to listen to
me overanalyze the Deaf diary video give
my opinion about useless stuff and
probably ramble for quite a while
incoherently
then this video might just suit your
needs small disclaimer before I get
started though this is obviously all
just my opinion and my take on things
and I might get some things wrong and
also many things that I'll talk about
I couldn't have noticed without being
pointed out but if awesome people at the
planet coaster forums and shyguys world
also I am not paid by frontier in any
way I just figured I would make this
video and look at the video itself
looking behind what they actually talk
about and to see what actually means for
the game and what you can do with it and
what my opinion is on it now go through
the video in a chronological order the
first thing that obviously piqued my
interest was this shot of a queue which
even though it I feel like it looks a
little bit empty I really like for the
reason that it shows some theme park
understanding usually in real life
queues are they sort of dragging down
part of the theme park which is really
boring and as a thing but you kind of
want to prevent that from happening
which is why they are so many themed
queues with their own queue music and
stuff like that and I really feel like
this references that as well in a way
since there is that little bit just
outside the queue just to make sure that
if you want to have something to eat you
can at least get rid of your trash in a
nice way what you do often see in real
life as well and having that scenery
around the queue just to make sure that
it's not this boring dragging down parts
but the queue is part of the theme park
experience as you want to see in at
least a high level theme park and now I
feel this show that's just pure eye
candy doesn't really say too much about
the game but I just love the perspective
and lighting at this as well also some
fair amount of detail and really good
reflections I feel on the material of
the ferris wheel itself and really I
feel like this shot of the roller
coaster
is also just I can it doesn't really say
too much other than the fact that this
is something that I really like the
rocks blend really really well with the
terraforming and really the bushes over
there blend quite well with the grass as
well and that just results in a pretty
good shot and going down this tunnel
like that I'm not to talk about the big
thing over here the coaster builder
like they're doing at this part of the
video and I feel like this coaster
builder even though it is piece by piece
and they try to go out of the way to
actually explain how they feel like they
can justify a piece by piece as being
controllable I feel like they don't even
have to say it in the video because the
video itself without even the audio
really shows that controllable aspects
of the piece by piece creating and what
I feel is quite important about this is
that you have a similar no similar style
of making tracks in a 3d environment as
a node editor but the major issue with a
node editor is that in a 3d environment
dragging nodes around is so very
uncontrollable it's so very hard to
actually control where your note is
gonna be in terms of height and where
you're gonna drag it around and for a
very instance no-limits has sort of
stepped over this hurdle by having the
different views like the top view in the
side view and the 3d view in the front
view etc and I feel like this is
actually a good way to get that
controllable aspects without having to
have different views so to keep the sort
of the flexibility in the coaster
builder without having to sacrifice any
user-friendliness aspects and I feel
like this is a coaster builder in which
you can do a lot since you have that
separate control of the heights and also
the horizontal movement of the track and
the banking and where it's actually
gonna go and what direction it's gonna
go into and I feel like these are good
controls that are useful are easy to use
but also give you enough control over
the track in a 3d environment to not get
completely lost and have to take away
separate nodes to get your track to
actually go where you want it to go so
this looks really good to me and
we're only thing I'm worried about might
be that you can't go back to your notes
and edit them later on but hopefully
that'll be the case I couldn't look into
that because I do see this type of
system being quite hard to actually get
to the exact place where you want to get
your track although obviously some
things to note about this and this was
pointed out at the planet coaster forums
is that the test button is actually not
completely visible and this sort of
suggests that you can't actually test
your coaster while you're building it
like you could involve a co second three
which would really be a shame because
that is really really handy option it is
good to see the autocomplete though
because without an honor complete button
I think it would be impossible to
actually get back to this station if you
have so much control over where the
track is gonna go exactly but overall I
think it's a really promising looking
track creator not sure what the two
icons are supposed to be that both look
like a station it doesn't really seem to
be a launch section unless those icons
are just not complete and also this is
still a work in progress so maybe I
shouldn't comment about this too much
maybe I should get on to the next thing
so this shot actually put some people
off and personally it put me off as well
since you can really see those jagged
lines on top of the lift Hill which is
also confusing because some of the other
is shots show a really smooth and not
jagged like this coaster what I would
like to say about this though is that
it's really cool to actually see what I
think is an anti rollback system on the
track and not just the lifting itself
but also those triangles that stick out
to make sure that the coaster car can't
actually roll back once they lift home
Achille fills which is really cool to
see though that said the lifts still
doesn't actually seem to be moving and I
don't know if that's because it let go
of the coaster which I'm really not sure
if that's actually the case or whether
it is because it just doesn't really
move yet and it still has to be animated
also something I want to quickly touch
upon is the fact that there doesn't
actually seem to be a hard line option
at all and this coaster is definitely
not
when they do banking and while that is
still alright for an arrow coaster I
would be slightly worried about not
having Bank I hard-lined bnm coasters
later on and maybe it's something that
will still be added it isn't going to be
a huge difference if it's not going to
be added but it would really help the
realism and smoothness of coasters but
yeah the overall opinion that I have the
coaster builder is religious that it
sort of what they say in the video I
feel like it really manages to strike
the balance between being usable but
also very flexible it really looks like
a coaster builder which you can easily
learn without having to do with a steep
learning curve like you would with no
limits one but still give you a lot of
control over where you're going and not
make it too hard to actually build your
coasters and it really seems like a
coaster builder that just very casual
players can work with and make the
wildest coasters of their dreams and
really the coaster enthusiasts can make
some realistic coasters with as well and
now something that jmr actually pointed
out is that it's really cool to see
those animatronics on the buildings as
well like that cannon sticking out of
the building like that and many of the
animatronics that you saw in games
earlier than this one we're sort of
fixed to a certain place on the ground
and you couldn't really integrate them
into scenery too well particularly
really cool to see that these are so
flexible and if these are actually
separate elements that you can put onto
your balls like the other assets are
that would be really amazing also it's
very clear I think in this shot is and
this might just be a trick of angles but
it really seems like there are different
models for the palm trees not just
different sizes with different models as
well and they really sway in the wind
which you'll see later on in the show of
this video as well but that's something
that makes me very happy now I don't
remember who it was but one of the devs
actually on the forum said that they put
a lot of effort into the small things of
the game as well all the way down to the
bolts of these supports and the others
really proves that there are some
amazing flanges on these supports with
even rendered bolts not just in a
texture but actually 3d bolts and it
looks really great and in a realistic
way too
in mine is a coaster supports are sort
of split up into different themes that
are all transported to the sides and
then put together and put together at
the bolts at the flanges and it's really
called actually see not just Blanche's
that look realistic but also actually
placed at the right places of the
supports not to mention that the support
structure over here overall especially
for a support structure that
automatically generated is really good
with all the different themes that
connect to each other in a typically
Aero hypercoaster fashion now here
they're talking about and showing of the
inversion tab of the game where other
than just a simple helix our number of
inversions over here and part of me is
really happy about this and part of me
isn't too happy about this so far
because there's a lot of control that
they actually have over the loop and
really what direction it's gonna go in
to get that slight curve over here where
you can really determine where exactly
the loop is gonna go which is really
good the loop actually looks very well
shaped as well but they come as sort of
entire predetermined loops corkscrews
and i'm and a sidewinder elements by the
looks of it at the bottom there quick
note in hindsight I brain fighted and it
was actually a double Sidewinder element
so it's a batwing
should be mixing of my coaster elements
but the thing is they come as
predetermined elements so you don't have
as much freedom anymore to for example
get a half loop and then be like the
coma
about it and put a dive loop next to it
and make something stupid like goo
durricks but the entire inversion is
already predetermined and you can't you
don't really have as much freedom
anymore as putting together different
loops and corkscrew types and dive loops
to make new types of elements which is
something that I kind of would love to
see so I sort of hope that more of the
more will be added to this or eventually
there'll be more freedom in what you can
do with this and if anybody knows about
anything that I'm saying or any
limitations that I'm complaining about
please please do comment about it
because I am definitely missing some of
the messages that the developers set out
there as well but this is actually
something which I'm not too happy about
and I sort of have this double feeling
about this
courts as well as their explaining in
here these supports automatically change
to whatever you're doing with the track
and by the looks of this it is actually
really good
there aren't any hits with the coaster
track to support you look really good
but part of me still wants to have
custom supports is nothing can really
beat the customization but also the
creativity of custom supports but this
is something that they're looking into
and I'm not really gonna complain about
it's just a small thoughts but it's it's
already known and they might get it in
the future
anyway these supports look really
amazing it wouldn't even be too much of
an issue if there aren't going to be
custom supports but it's just a thoughts
that I always want to keep in my mind
and the way that terraforming works with
the coaster builder over here is
something that I've always wished for as
well it's really good
as jmr pointed out in roller coaster in
three terraforming with coasters it's
just a nightmare would come up with
weird lowkey things would totally ruin
any of the terraforming you had if you
wanted to make a tunnel held there
weren't even tunnels in the original
base game of roller coaster good three
and you needed soaked for that and this
system seems so much better to use much
more user-friendly it doesn't actually
mess up your environment at all
I kid in a way these tunnels look really
cool and other they sort of go up with
with the rest of the rocket environments
the only thing that I sort of have to
say about this is that the coaster trick
seems a bit too low I'm into high
actually when you compare it to the
entire size of the tunnel and it seems
like people that are going to be sitting
in this coaster will continuously scrape
their heads along the ceiling of this
tunnel and it's like the tunnel is
created around the spine of the coaster
track rather than I had a hard line and
if you like the coaster track it just be
a little lower in the tunnel just to
give a bit of headroom but yeah aside
from that tunnels look really cool
also this rabbit goes through traffic
card oh man I don't know what to say
about this I love it but it's it's fun
to see developers have fun with Ryota
coaster cars I suppose also this is a
pretty good shot for looking at the
photos which I have to say it look
really good as well really happy about
how that looks so far and here you can
even see
the reals where the wheels actually
touch the rails even has you know no
paint on it as you would usually see in
real life and then there's the gift shop
story which made me so happy it's
actually hereabouts because in real life
you really have that the gift shops
behind right where you come out of a
coaster of course you have those gift
shops and of course it really works
there is an idea behind that that people
want to buy stuff when they actually get
run out of coaster and see all this
stuff in a gift shop and it's really
cool to see them actually apply video
theme park logics into the game like
this and even though it's just a small
thing to me it really shows that a lot
of research and ideas and of course also
a lot of experience with previous
coaster games as frontier has went into
this game and this scene over here is
just really beautiful how the employees
are sort of standing there and this
employees just kind of walking around
there don't know what's up with the
texture of the come through though but
it is a good shot and of course the man
eating ice cream is an amazing shot as
well really loved that too just a really
great animation on the topic of
animations by the way there have been so
many comments on all of the planet
coaster videos in Facebook and YouTube
of people being like wow this is nearly
picture level animation and that for a
game in which is really interesting and
what stream actually pointed out on
shaggers well special shout-out to
stream by the way was a very old barely
viewed interview with the developers of
planet coaster and what actually turns
out is that some of the animation team
actually has worked with Pixar and
Disney before so yeah in a way there is
a legacy of Pixar in these animations
which really surprised me and god these
animations are so good
I don't really know where I went with
that story anyway I just figured it
would be cool to know that as much as
these animations remind many people of
Pixar animations in a way it's actually
true now this is a shot of them one of
the worst coasters I've ever seen
designed in life it looks really funny
though
but it was pointed out that at the forum
service was just a result of overzealous
strike building but what I would like to
say about this particular shot is that
even though the coast route doesn't
actually look good if you just sort of
squint your eyes this shot has some of
the most realistic lighting I've ever
seen in a theme park game and this
almost looks like real life if you take
out the weirdness of the layouts and
also there is a lift Hill and a rollback
safety mechanism on the track which
doesn't really make any sense because
this is not the lift Hill but you can
clearly see how the lift Hill is gonna
work gonna look over here and what's
also really cool about this shots is the
connectors which actually have the track
have the color of the track and actually
Square as you would have with arrow and
4-koma coasters so that is a really good
touch of detail as well oh and you can
actually see the ports of the coaster
track on the ties over there I think you
can just see the bolts connecting the
ties to the spine and what is the left
hell which is really cool they even have
these triangular caps which supports
have as they go through a curve and they
even have these slanted automatically
these slanted beams as the coaster goes
through a curb and just these straight
supports as the coaster just has a
straight piece of track which it is
really good to see and this part also
caused quite a buzz because they're
talking about dark rides which is really
cool and it's not just cool because I
the thing is pretty much everything
which is shown over here pretty much
shows that dark ride will most likely be
a possibility especially given that dark
rides weren't even given a thought for
all echo ii 3 and people have been able
to make amazing dark rides in
rollercoaster 2 & 3 without it actually
being a point of the intended based game
and no even without the developers
saying anything about dark rides in this
game it looks like a game in which you
can make dark rides thanks to the
modular building tools and the way that
lighting works in the game but hearing
the developers actually talk about the
possibility of dark rides just helped so
much because that I'll just make sure
that there might actually be extra tools
for dark rides and ways in which you can
really incorporate dark rides into
you park without having to mess with
being too creative with the tools that
the game is given or perhaps mods at
some time in the future which is really
nice and again it's one of those points
which you do often find in theme parks
which is at least good to know that the
developers have looked at and are
thinking about adding also it's really
cool to see this ferris wheel by the way
it's not just a normal ferris wheel but
it looks like very much inspired by the
ferris wheel in Disneyland California
with the big Mickey Mouse and stuff
where it also has that track with the
swinging cars no way that I would ever
want to get into this ferris wheel but
it looks like it's a pretty rare type of
ferris wheel too so to see it actually
in the game and actually look this good
realistic and detailed is really cool
also one really good thing about this
shot I think is this little sandy path
in front here and I've always been
really happy about the curbs and that
the paths have over here and how neatly
they are sort of organized in the rest
of the environments but over here you
can actually see a path that doesn't
have curves around it and seems to be
very free and where it sort of flows
with that sand but it still has path
elements on it and Sandy paths like this
would be absolutely magical in a theme
park now this shoulder is just more eye
candy I suppose and but especially the
way in which the employee actually walks
around in the little store is really
nice to see but the entire story about
having a basic structure in which you
add things to make things really look
the way you want them to there is
something that really appeals to me at
least since what I really hope will be
how this modular building is going to
work in the end especially as you create
larger and more detailed structures it
is really getting in the basic walls and
getting a basic idea of what your facade
is and then gradually start adding the
details to really make it to really add
to the atmosphere and the overall look
of the building and what is quite often
a tedious thing in roller-coaster 3
having to plan out your facades and
using special facades that's first
before you remove them and get to your
actual buildings or sometimes just
starting to build a building but then in
the end it doesn't really come out the
way you
in terms of shape it really feels like
this might be a way of modular building
in which you can prevent that by really
having the opportunity to really add the
basis first and have the details and
ornaments and accents as extra added
things which is slowly gradually add to
the building and it really makes sure
that you can really get these shape and
overall composition right first and get
the details in later if I interpreted
what he said in that case right I have
really hope that's how it's going to
work out eventually it's also really
cool to see all the woodwork in the
round tower in the background there
because it's very very detailed with all
the different ropes and wooden things
that look very off-grid as well and of
course the centerpiece of this show is
the mascot which is really cool to see
don't really have to add too much to
that I do have to say Gopi is still my
favorite
now about this shot Jay Mohr actually
said that the water looks way too a park
and they might want to change that but
I'm actually not sure if that's a clear
water in the cave over there especially
how there are bushes and this Park has
boats littered everywhere be there water
or knots I feel like it's really just a
ornamental small cave part to just show
off what you can actually do with caves
and how you can sort of decorate your
Park with them now this point that some
Danny explains really I think echos what
I've been thinking about the entire park
is that the scenery really is part of
the environment and when it goes up in
it but doesn't really just stand there
on its own often what you had in Veliko
sigma3 and I especially felt with the
science fiction related scenery that I
wish was something you sort of plopped
down but it doesn't actually have any
relation with the environment you can't
really mix it in too well and what I
really find with the scenery over here
is that as basic as it is at the moment
and there aren't really any themes other
than what they've shown so far it really
mixes and blends with the environment
now this shot seems to have an
anti-aliasing glitch going on on the
captain's hats or his entire body rather
it's still pretty good shot overall
really good lighting again and this this
scene I personally
love from like the overall atmosphere
the way that the entertainers work
around you really got that very very
nice atmosphere from it the animation on
the hamburger over here is just so
detailed and you can see every part of
the hamburger flopping around like it's
some sort of silicone we think that's
way too hot to be inside of and that
family just following it which is very
funny
and I like the parts about the online
things as well just because it's of
course an idea that in this day and age
you can't really miss out on any more
especially given what other simulation
and strategy and more sandbox like games
have done with this online aspect it's
also really cool to see the use the
lorem ipsum meat generator to get some
bacon ipsum in there which is really
cool just it's it's some of those
touches where I really feel like
frontier isn't always too serious about
this like one Lee coaster in the first f
time or the second I don't remember
exactly what's called the booty rattler
stuff like that really to me
hats flavor to the game sorry about that
but it's really there when frontier sort
of meets my expectations I think is
what's usually in the community referred
to as really the greatest shots in this
entire video and I think I'm gonna go
along with that and be perspective is
really amazing there's a lot of
foreground/background going on and it's
really cool to see these palm trees sway
in the wind and especially this palm
tree like there's three palm trees over
here and the right one seems much more
crooked number two looking ones on the
left of it and I'm not really sure this
might be a trick with the angle but it
really looks like there are going to be
actual unique tree models and not just
different sizes and the way they sway in
the wind it's not just beautifully
animated but it's also uneven they don't
always sway the exact same way like in
the beginning of the shots it's not a
more still and then at the end it's like
a big wind passes by and they sway a bit
more it seems which is really cool to
see as well the bloom on the fence is
going absolutely crazy though I do have
to say they bloom i overall like it but
that's just one of those things which
sort of looks a bit
unfinished I mean again it's still a
work in progress but I can't help but
notice that and feel that it sticks out
like a sore thumb in this otherwise very
good-looking video and about this shot
over here as much as I like it in the
foreground you could see a sort of Plaza
but you can tell that they are trying to
make a plaza with just regular path type
elements and I would really love to see
an actual plot applause a mechanic in
addition to the rest of the path
mechanics and this is something which I
don't think has ever been responded to
by the developers but to be able to make
some of those larger squares with
restaurants and just where you can sit
down and have a cup of tea or something
like that would be really great in this
game as well not being forced to make
your classes by having planters in the
middle all the time would be an amazing
addition so coming at the end of the
video one thing that I really like about
what they're saying here is that they're
reflecting on how different people
interact with each other and make these
things and use each other's ideas to
create their own things and this is
really a very indirect way that I feel
to recognize what exactly I think is the
strength of not just the roller coaster
country but also roller coaster going 1
& 2 and other coaster and sim games
communities and it's really good to have
them recognize that and actually have
fun with it themselves as well and
really my general thoughts I suppose as
I should wrap them up at the end of this
video to maybe
neatly wrap up this video that's already
way too long with a final type of point
is that I just really feel like planet
coaster from what they're showing is
gonna be a really good game and there
are many different reasons and I can't
really wrap those reasons or up into one
a nice little package which I can
deliver in a couple minutes but here's
the thing which I would like to talk
about instead I get this feeling with
every single thing that the planet
coaster developers share and this goes
for the dev Diaries as well it's all
parts of one greater plan our a concept
behind the entire game like we're just
seeing snippets of what is the final
plan
like there's some sort of foreboding
feeling that this is just a part of it
and you can only fully experience it
yourself when you actually get the game
and this is really what makes me most
happy about it because they're not just
making these videos to show off that
they're actually getting something done
and they don't want to just prove hey
look we're making this game and this
game is looking good but I always I also
get this feeling of this is just part of
it and you'll have to see the rest for
yourself and we are not even getting
started yet and while it's something
that I can't exactly prove and it's
something that I can't lay my finger on
on yeah this is exactly why it's like
that this is something that really makes
me put a lot of hope and also impatience
to play this game and yeah that's
basically my final sort of thoughts this
game is far from perfect and I want to
refrain from stepping on any type of
hype train but it's really hard to read
not enter the hype train for a planet
coaster yet it really looks good and
there are so many different things which
I like about it and so many things which
are very promising about the game since
the developers not only have so much
knowledge and experience within the
genre but I also genuinely think that
there is passion behind it
since this really is very special for
them as well being their actual
independence company release rather than
having to listen to a certain producer
just hiring them as a developer and I'm
pretty much just looking forward to see
more of them and discussing this game I
suppose in the comments section or
wherever it'll be in the future anyway
thanks for watching this random video
which turned out to be way too long
I could keep talking for quite a long
time but I'll really have to wrap it up
over here so thanks for watching and see
you guys later